oh my god it felt like i just did drugs
or something i felt like i was trying to
faint like it was
a whole different feeling that was the
worst tattoo i got and that was the
smallest tattoo i ever got
my first tattoo i was like 14 15 years
old
i was in birmingham alabama that's
before i was famous and everything i
wanted my auntie it was like a
tattoo parlor like around the corner
from my house and i was begging my mom i
was like hey man let me get a tattoo
like i was gonna surprise her get my uh
get her name on it too like on my arm it
didn't even hurt that bad for i thought
it was gonna be like worse everybody was
telling me yeah bruh
the first tattoo is the worst it's gonna
kill you i got my mom name
i showed it to her she wasn't even mad
for real i was like oh yeah from now on
this is i'm gonna get inky
my 90s baby tattoo on my arm i've been
had the image of what i wanted on my arm
and i went on the top left arm for sure
but when i got it
it was fatter than it was supposed to be
because i got a skinnier arm
but it came out right like i got a fat
ass me on my arm
with my favorite baseball team you feel
me i got the number 44 because that was
like my uh
my number when i played baseball and
played sports when i was younger
my favorite channel nickelodeon when i
was younger like and i missed the bounce
all with that photo and all that
like i always had luck with fofo so i
was going towards like the boom docs
type of thing like you know like huey
streaming
like riley and all them type kind of
going off of that but like more
realistic to like me type but it's still
a cartoon character damn near on my arm
what inspired me to get tattoos i used
to look up like the cholo
little drawings on youtube and try to
draw them out like copy and put my piece
of paper on the screen and like outline
it
always been into like graffiti and
tattoos so it really wasn't like
all right i seen him or her with cold
tattoos and i got to get a tattoo
my cousin he was the first person around
me that had a tattoo he had a fat
tattoo in the back of his neck i was
like yeah when i get my neck inky i'm
gonna have to go
crazy because my most recent piece that
i got on my neck i got like an angel on
the side of my neck
and i got the eye of providence and i
got
some converses in my block numbers you
feel me like where i'd be at
in the street name i got angels
protecting me like watching over me for
the iron providence while i'm on the
blocker while i'm outside doing whatever
i'm doing or why i'm
making music or doing whatever like it's
something that's there for me type
only i would understand it unless i
explained it
i got st mary on my arm it's like a sign
to where my mom watching me while i'm
doing everything like you feel me my mom
always got my back like i feel like my
mom is the
the biggest influence in my life i had
to get something that represent her
like other than just her name like for
me i got it right next to her name too
this arm is like mainly like spiritual
like i got a bunch of gases on my arm in
this gating right here like i got my
eyes everything around me on my my body
is mainly family
and stuff that's connecting with me in
real life instead of just getting
on my arms and on my body the most
painful one was the smallest tattoo i
got like i got a lifeline
it's like a little red heart in it i
couldn't even finish it like i swear to
god like i woke up one day
and my homeboy he was like yeah i'm
going away from oc like i'm gonna put
love like i remember you told me you
wanted a tattoo today
so i wake up right when he there he
already at my house i go in the living
room
like i ain't gonna eat nothing ain't
gonna drink nothing let me go and get
his tattoo
i'm smoking the blunt he put the needle
on me i'm like oh my god it felt like i
just did drugs or something i felt like
i was gonna faint like it was
a whole different feeling that was the
worst tattoo i got and that was the
smallest tattoo i ever got because i was
dehydrated i didn't eat or nothing
and you feel me it was painful as hell
that's the smallest tattoo but it's on
my wrist
my favorite tattoo artist is the only
tattoo artist i let work on me my boy
hershel everybody know herself he do
blue face tattoos he do
little scotch tattoos that's the only
person i go to he did my neck he did my
arms everything
i really want to get my hands hit i
probably might get something like yeah
i'm gonna feel my neck out like
it's filled out already but i'm gonna
get some more stuff added to it i'm
gonna get my hands done my chest done
uh the face type trend really don't
matter no more like back in the day i
used to be like damn people want to just
look hard
but now i understand people got a
purpose for what they getting like i
don't really look at it like no type of
way no more i wouldn't get a face tattoo
i probably get something like
small like on the side of my ear or
something like that but like
not no face tattoo you know what i'm
saying but anybody got a face tattoo
they don't know
they got a reason that they got it for i
got a theme to my right arm and my left
arm like you feel me this is just like
all right my first starting i could put
anything on his arm
and it mattered to me and i could do
anything with this arm but this arm
i gotta flow with it like my gazes and
everything and kind of match with each
other
this arm is kind of like putting stuff
everywhere you know i'm saying that my
neck and kind of feel everything y'all
like i kind of put
something that was represented on this
side and something that was represented
on this side like so it all matches down
like with everything and like when i get
my middle in my chest it
don't match with the middle of my neck
so i'm doing everything like
with a flop any tattoos i regret getting
none to be honest i got all my tattoos
in the right place and at the right time
so you tell me all my tattoos mean
something to me i don't have nothing to
cover up so
it's not like i got a girl name or
something like a name that i didn't want
so you know what i'm saying like all my
tattoos is cool like it means to me